thank you very much mr. chairman Jim
thanks for being with us today I
strongly concur with Senator Conrad's
comments about what a disastrous budget
this is and the very negative impact
that it will have in the future of this
country and our kids and our
grandchildren but I want to take this
discussion a little bit away from the
issue of the national debt as important
as that is and the deficit to talk about
what this budget means to ordinary human
beings and to try to understand the
moral values that have been placed in
this budget or I perhaps should say the
lack of moral values a senator bunning a
moment ago talked about tax burdens in
this country but let me talk about who
pays the taxes who earns the money in
this country mr. director is I'm sure
you're aware the United States has by
far the most unequal distribution of
income and wealth of any major country
on Earth and increasingly we're looking
more like Brazil in Mexico than we are
like Europe and Scandinavia and other
industrialized countries when Senator
Conrad talks about legacy for this
president what we should be aware of
since President Bush has been in office
5 million more people have slipped into
poverty the middle class has shrunk
median family income has declined by
over a thousand dollars eight million
Americans have lost their health
insurance three million Americans have
lost their pensions and yes some people
have done very well and those are the
people on top and all of the statistics
that we throw out around here I want to
throw out one statistic I don't want to
get your comment on it direct the Nussle
according to the latest reports from the
IRS the wealthiest one-tenth of 1%
one-tenth of 1% 300,000 men women and
children now earn more income than do
the bottom 150
million Americans one tenth of one
percent more income than fifty percent
of the american people and that gap is
growing wider what is your sense about
what it means to the future of this
country and economic justice that we
have such an unequal distribution of
income and wealth well first of all miss
mr. sanders senator i have have not
thought about that question I will I
will I don't you think it's a question
that we should think about I will give
it some thought I have given some
thought to tax distribution and tax
reform and I would agree with you that
our tax code needs to be reformed and
there are there are problems within our
tax code that that need to be rooted out
we have the top one percent of the tax
code of the people paying taxes in this
country pay forty percent of all of the
taxes the top five percent pay fifty
nine person I've just given you an
example of the fact that the wealthiest
one-tenth of 1% earn more income than do
the bottom fifth Nathan they also pay
taxes to us they pay taxes but not
proportionate to what they aren't let me
ask you another question of morale let's
forget about being in the United States
Senate let's get down to basic morality
in your budget you propose over seven
hundred billion dollars in tax breaks
for the wealthiest three-tenths of 1%
seven hundred billion dollars in tax
breaks for millionaires and billionaires
at the same time as you want to
eliminate among other programs or the
low-income weatherization assistance
program as you want to make massive cuts
in the LIHEAP program which you are very
familiar with well in Vermont and all
over this country in Iowa I dare say it
is getting cold older people cannot
afford to keep their homes warm what is
the moral justification for giving over
seven hundred billion dollars in tax
breaks to millionaires and Bill
and then cut back on programs which keep
people warm which provide health care
for desperate people and which provide
many other basic necessities could be
the moral justification for that the the
tax cuts that the president proposed in
2001 and 2003 are distributed much
further than the top one-tenth of one
but I give you example of how it impacts
the top one three tenths of one percent
seven hundred billion dollars tell me
why the richest people in this country d
tax breaks you labadee is increasing I
would I would I would guess under that
that you received a tax cut I may have
but I'm talking about millionaires and
billionaires and I don't need a tax
break you don't need a tax break tell me
what I should the rich I don't I need a
tax break because you're doing well that
other people are going hungry in America
and people are the middle class is
shrinking and so it's my responsibility
i'm not talking about you I'm talking
about millionaires and build own take
then take anyone as attack I'll give you
an example you want to repeal the estate
tax is that correct all of the benefits
of the estate tax go to the richest
three-tenths of one percent if the
estate tax is completely repealed the
walton family which is worth eighty
billion dollars which owns Walmart's
will get over thirty billion dollars in
tax relief do you think the walton
family needs 30 billion dollars in tax
reliefs when you're cutting back on
health care when you're cutting back on
programs that feed hungry people hungry
senior citizens let me hear the moral
your administration talks a lot about
morality and family values now tell me
about the morality are giving tax breaks
to the walton family worth eighty
billion dollars in cutting back on the
needs of the most desperate bill and
throw in there a justification for
raising the fees for our veterans who
are getting into the VA hospital
significantly increasing them which will
drive veterans off of the VA now these
are the these are the veterans who have
incomes that are higher than yeah twenty
seven thousand dollars a year in other
words I want to hear em man to man man
to man you tell me about tax breaks for
billionaires and cutting back on the
needs of veteran
that one company first of all I don't
know what the tax bill is for the Walton
family I don't know how much they pay my
estimate is they will save 30 billion
dollars through the repeal of the estate
tax tell me why they need a 30 billion
what do they do with that 30 billion
dollars then I have no idea but i will
tell you but my my bet is that there
they are quite philanthropic as are many
in that situation and again i don't have
personal knowledge about what they do
with it but they earned it i'm glad
you're concerned about the walton family
some of us are concerned about no you
brought up the walton family i don't
even know them I've never met them I am
I have they don't live it you're worried
your your administration is predicted
are not worried i don't think the
Waltons would tell you they oughta that
we ought to be worried about them either
good probably not senator Gregg I'm mr.
chairman if I might just as a point of
personal privilege take a couple minutes
here and then yield to Center out and
later i'll come back and reclaim the
balance of my time i do think it's
important on this tax policy issue
because senator sanders and as usual
elegance has raised the issue presenting
the vermont approach to it let me
present a new hampshire approach to it
if you could put up the first chart
under the under the tax policy which we
presently have today we are generating
more in revenues than we have
historically generated we're up to about
18 point seven percent of gross national
product is now coming in in revenues as
compared with 18.2 percent of gross
national product please put up the
second chart and the highest twenty
percent of taxpayers in this country
income tax payers today are paying more
in taxes as a percentage of the total
burden than they were during the Clinton
administration in other words the top
end of american income people are paying
more in taxes as a percentage of the
total burden of our federal tax burden
then the lower than they were under the
clinton time if you go to the next chart
and presently today the bottom forty
percent the people who having earned
income in this country are getting more
back most of them don't pay income taxes
they get an earned income tax credit
they're getting more back in tax benefit
through the eitc almost twice as much as
they got under the clinton period so we
now have a tax law which first generates
more revenue more revenue than has
historically been generated for the
federal government second taxes
people at the high income and generates
more revenue from high-income
individuals and third gives back more
income to people in the lower income
brackets that's called progressivity
it's also called a tax policy that works
why does it work human nature human
nature you give people a reasonable tax
rate which is what we've done you give
it people a reason to go out and be
productive to take that risk to be the
entrepreneur to create that new job they
create economic activity economic
activity does one very big thing it
creates jobs for Americans it does the
second very big thing it creates a
revenue for the federal government and
that's what our tax policy is done under
this administration so I happen to
disagree with the senator from Vermont
we do disagree that's why he lives in
vermont and I live in New Hampshire we
had the lowest tax burden per capita in
the country they have one of the highest
that's just a fundamental difference
well my friend from New Hampshire yield
for a brief sec I do not and I want to
reclaim my client not a mind I'm image
but I'm sure you'll get another second
that was my interlude and I also might
note you've got a lot of people
immigrating to New Hampshire to I assume
that has to do with the lower tax break
yes and we have a few people who come
over from Vermont occasionally to buy a
bottle of liquor and we appreciate that
well thank you for thank you for that
point of it because you know that's the
point I wanted to make senator Greg is
that we've seen revenues increase not
only at the federal level with the tax
cuts of 2001 and 2003 but we've also in
seen revenues increase at the state
level